foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with economos Carol
Malone
and the political editor at the
Liverpool Echo Liam thought they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
well the Metro marks the first
anniversary of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine with this evocative picture of
Ukrainian Flags in a graveyard plus its
own front page from a year ago and the
headline Heroes never give in
this is the front of the times the
headline there Ukraine's year of blood
the telegraph reports that the
Archbishop of Canterbury is warning that
Russia must not be crushed or we risk a
country left in the same state as
Germany after the first world war which
ended in the rise of Hitler
the mirror leads on the shortages of
fruit and veg in our shops and ridicules
the environment secretary for her
apparent comment let them eat turnips
The Daily Star has an almost identical
front page headline
email carries criticism from the queen
consort it moves to change some of Roald
Dahl's books in what's been called awoke
re-writing
that's also the top story in tomorrow's
Express
the financial times reports on President
Biden's domination of a new president of
the World Bank with a brief to expand
the fight against climate change
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Carol Malone and Liam Thorpe welcome
back to both of you let us start with
the metro and that um headline the
poignant picture first of all of the uh
the flags
um and this being in a a graveyard with
the Ukrainian flags flying
they've taken their headline from a year
ago so Heroes never give up you take us
into this first of all Carol
evocative picture because we know now
that a hundred thousand military have
either been wounded or killed we know
that 80 000 civilians have been killed
uh there's something like I can't
remember how many refugees hundreds of
thousands of refugees it's it's you know
this is a tragic situation people
thought this war will be over in a few
days
um and he's been improved wrong one hour
and tomorrow will be the 365th today
um and it shouldn't be happening it's
it's it's incredibly sad you know the
country is almost raised but it's really
hard to see how and where this war will
end because we all know Putin psyche we
all know what he's like he has to be
seen to be given something before he
will give this up and by the same token
zelenski has said time and time again he
will not give an hinge back of the land
that they have taken back so it's really
hard to see how this is going to end the
only way it can end as if as if we all
give him the the weapons to finish this
war off as Boris said tonight it's Gotta
you know he's got to be given enough
weapons to expand Russians from Ukraine
it is a terrible terrible War
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians left
home as we have some of them this
country thank God we can take care of
them but apparently just depending on
Ukraine to pull back to give in he
really needs to have another thing
because that is never going to happen we
see we saw that was zelenski when he was
when he came here to try and get weapons
when he went around Europe he's never
giving in to the people aren't giving in
they would follow him to hell and back
although arguably that's exactly where
they are right now and Liam a year later
we're not even at the stage of any
semblance of peace talks are we
no and I don't think that's ever going
to happen from Putin's side is it's it's
not something that that he entertains as
an idea I think you know myself and some
colleagues have been speaking to um some
Ukrainian refugees in in this country in
Liverpool where we are and I think it's
speaking to them just reminds us because
I think we can become a bit annoyed to
some of these images it's been a year
and obviously the news cycle kind of
moves up and down but just going back to
the you know when those bombs first
started dropping and speaking to people
today who have had to basically get up
they were woken up by the sound of bombs
in their in their near their Gardens had
to pack a rucksack and just leave
everything behind that some of the
images that they told us about what they
saw you know making their way through
different countries Poland and Romania
and then eventually you know finding a
way to come in and and start a new life
in in England and and I'm very proud
that we've been able to do that but
these people should never have had to do
anything like that and you know they
will never forgive Putin and as far as
Ukraine into consent there is no other
answer than to kick Russia fully out of
Ukraine there is there is no negotiating
with a man like Putin it just doesn't
happen so so from their perspective and
the people I've spoken to the only
answer to this is to get rid of Russia
out of Ukraine we've obviously seen how
just how remarkable the fight back has
been from the ukrainians but they're
running out of steam and and that's why
they want that's why they want more
suppliers more weapons from from Europe
and obviously the UK are kind of leading
on that yes and Carol the financial
times reminds us that a year on Vladimir
Putin's invasion of Ukraine that the war
has killed or injured more than 200 000
Russian armed forces and that's
according to to Western officials so I
mean it's not as if there hasn't been a
a hefty toll for for Russia
I know we know that we've received story
after story about how a lot of the
Russian soldiers don't want to be there
they're running away you know Putin's
made it clear that only Russian soda who
runs away will be shot but you know they
don't want to be there either he's
taking people who are soldiers from you
know from towns and cities and sending
them to to be basically fodder it's a
pointless pointless War but Liam was
dead right there and what struck me
today is we're all talking about this
because it's a 12-month anniversary but
you know there are lots of days that
Ukraine isn't in the news at all and yet
every single day those people are going
through hell you know their their towns
and cities have been raised the economy
is wrecked you know the infrastructure
is entirely gone they're living this day
after day after day and we're sitting in
our homes going I wasn't that terrible
but then we move on and and that's
what's not going to be allowed to happen
I mean it's really it's you know I keep
trying to imagine myself in that
situation to to remind myself to keep
reading about this and doing what you
can and talking about it because it's
really important that we don't let this
slide to the bottom of our useless and
stop talking about it I think what's
good though is that no what this war has
done is United Europe together again
it's brought that it's brought the U.S
back again and and hopefully we're all
helping and hopefully when when they all
pull their fingers out they will get the
weapons that they actually need to
finish this war because they're not
giving up Liam what what do you make up
the Archbishop of canterbury's um
comments in the telegraph that Russia
must not be crushed in any Ukraine peace
deal
yeah I think it's really really
interesting um he's you know he's he's
not shy from uh from you know getting
involved in in some political
discussions and and he's usually worth
listening to um Justin Welby
um I I think he makes a good point here
but it's very easy we we all think what
Putin's done is is horrific and and
catastrophic but and it's very easy to
say you know just Russia should be
crushed to us and into their life but
Justin Mobley is asking us to learn the
lessons from history you know Germany
was humiliated after the first world war
and look what happened next the most
disastrous thing that could ever have
happened in terms of the second world
war and the rise of Hitler so
he he is very clear that there is there
is the only way out of this is to to get
Russia out of Ukraine but the the he's
asking to learn the lessons of history
and you know you don't want you don't
want to repeat what we what we saw in in
the early part of this of the century
and you want to see some sort of some
sort of obviously some kind of
ramifications some kind of measures put
in place so they can't do this again but
yeah he's just asking to learn the
lessons there and I I think it's a
fairly Fair Point from the Archbishop
Carol yes he says that Russia must not
be allowed to repeat its aggression but
cannot end up like Germany after 1919
when Berlin was humiliated by being
forced to disarm and pay reparations
oh has Carol Frozen
yes I think uh Carol Carol has Frozen
um so Liam just to expand on your your
thoughts there that he's he's actually
saying that you know Russia mustn't be
allowed to repeat its aggression so that
they shouldn't be allowed to get away
with it but we have to think
um seriously about the I guess the the
force of of retaliation
yeah and also you know it's it's Putin
that should be punished for this and
when we we will hope that there will be
um War crime trials and and all those
things that that should should follow
this when hopefully this this horrific
War does end but it's not necessarily
the whole uh you know Russian people who
should be punished we saw people in
Germany who were impoverished and you
don't want to build up that further
resentment further different distance
between the Nations you know it it seems
a long way away at the moment but we
would hope to be at some point working
towards a more peaceful situation but
um the Archbishop does say as well you
know it's important to say Ukraine
shouldn't be forced into an unjust peace
their country is the one that's been
invaded you sometimes see people saying
why why aren't they negotiating that
their country has been invaded they've
seen no suggestion that at all from
Putin's side that there will be any
negotiations so that so for them the
priority and and the only result of this
is to is to get rid of Russia after that
the International Community can can come
together and make make a make a plan
Liam thank Q
coming up more from the Press preview
with the mirror which leads on the
shortages of fruit and veg in our shops
the headline reads let them eat turnips
stay with us for more
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
previews to with me CAM Malone and Liam
Thorpe County first of all uh let them
eat turnips who has said this and why
it's the front page of the moon's a
coffee who uh actually is the
environment secretary and and her
nickname is Calamity coffee and you can
see why when you read this story
um you know sure you know at the time
when everyone is struggling at a time
when there's there's no vegetables in
the shops who don't have any Tomatoes
people can't afford to buy them even if
there was she she didn't actually say
let them return us but what she's saying
is
um if you haven't got enough money you
should find a way to buy food you should
find a way to earn a bit more money I
mean that's not simply what she said
what she said was she the idea was to
get people back into work to earn money
that she should have stopped right there
I mean getting people back into work who
aren't working is a very good idea if
you want if you want to have a good
lifestyle however to carry on and stay
say what she said as soon as it seems
Kamikaze to me and it's just you know it
it's not even just reading the room
wrong it's reading the country wrong
it's reading your party wrong it's just
it's
calamitous crass thing to say at the
time like this I don't think it's a bad
woman I don't think it's a hard-hearted
woman it's just a really
really thing to say Liam what do you
think
yeah I mean I hate turnips
um and um yeah just I agree I mean I
must admit I can't really understand
um sometimes why trees of coffee is
continually in these these seriously
senior positions she's ever since she's
been in government she seems to make
Gaff after Gaff I I think you know to
turn around to people who are saying who
are seeing empty Supermarket shells with
they can't get the fresh vegetables that
they they want for a healthy life and to
turn around and say oh just let's just
eat eat this turn instead it just seems
it just seems and Carol thank you both I
think you're discriminating against
turnips at Lynn but thank you we'll see
we'll see you both in the 11. thank you